So we're going to return to
our one-dimensional elastic
collision with no
external forces.
So we have object 1 moving with
velocity V1 initial and object
2 maybe it's moving this
way with V2 initial i hat,
again, on a
frictionless surface.
And we'll call that
our initial state.
And here you can imagine we're
going to use a ground reference
frame.
So both objects are moving.
And our final state
has object 1-- well,
we don't know, again,
which way it's going.
We can just say it bounced back.
And object 2 also bounced back.
But the goal of our
problem, of course,
is to determine these vectors.
And by knowing the vectors,
we know which way they go.
Now because energy and
momentum are constant,
let's write down
our two equations.
And I'm going to
write them down,
again, in terms of components.
So we have 1/2 m1 V1x
initial squared plus 1/2
m2 V2x initial squared equals
1/2 m1 V1x final squared
plus 1/2 m2 V2x final squared.
Now we're going to do some
algebraic manipulations here.
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is just eliminate these halves
because it's not necessary.
And I don't want to
rewrite this equation.
And this is our fact that
our energy is constant.
And now our condition
that momentum is constant,
we'll write this-- now, I'm
going to leave a little space
here intentionally.
And our condition that
momentum is constant
is m1 Vx initial plus m2
V2x initial equals m1 V1x
final plus m2 V2x final.
Now this energy equation
can be factored in
by bringing all the m1 terms
to one side and the M2 terms
to the other side.
So when I write that,
I'll need a little room.
I have m1 V1x initial squared
minus V1x final squared.
And that's equal to
m2 V2x final squared
minus V2x initial squared.
So I've just brought those
terms over to the other side.
Now likewise I'll do the
same thing down here.
I have m1 V1x initial
minus V1x final.
And that's equal to m2 V2x
final minus V2x initial.
Now here comes the
algebraic trick
in which I'm going to
linearize these systems.
This is a squared
minus b squared,
which factors into a
plus b times a minus b.
So let's give ourselves
a little room.
m1 V1x initial plus-- let's
put the minus sign first.
minus V1x final times V1x
initial plus V1x final.
Factored that term.
We have the same factoring
on the other side.
So it's just
identical, V2x final
minus V2x initial times
V2x final plus V2x initial.
Now let's call this equation
1a and our momentum factored
as 2a.
Now if you notice,
the momentum piece
is appearing exactly
there and exactly here.
So when I divide 1a
by 2a-- and I'll just
symbolically represent that--
then these two pieces cancel.
And that leads to just this
term equal to that term.
And the significance, as
you'll see when I write it out,
1 of x 1x final equals V2x
final plus V2x initial.
I've solved the quad-- I've
eliminated the squared terms,
linearized the system.
Now I still want to write
this equation in another way.
Another important
point to notice
is that this equation
is independent of mass.
Now what I want to
do is write this
in terms of those concepts
of relative velocity we had.
Remember just to motivate
this, V relative by definition
was V1 minus V2.
So let's write this in terms
of the initial and the final.
So in order to do that, we
have to bring this initial term
over to here and this
final term over to there.
And so this equation, which
will give it a number 3,
and now we'll modify
that by calling it 3a.
We have V1x initial
minus V2x initial.
Now notice the sign.
I'm going to want to keep
the order of 1 and 2.
So I have to put a minus sign,
V1x final minus V2x final.
And when written this way,
this is the initial component
of the relative velocity.
And in there is the final
component of relative velocity.
So by combining
these two equations,
I have this remarkable result
that V relative initial
is minus V relative final.
And this condition is
a very powerful tool
for simply analyzing
one-dimensional elastic and
inelastic collisions.
I'd like to even
give this a name.
I'd like to call it the
energy momentum equation.
Now there's a lot of
significant things about this.
So let's just think
about it for a moment.
We have that V relative
initial in magnitude
is equal to V relative final.
And so right away, this
gives us some insight
into any collision.
We can see whether
a collision, if we
know what the relative
initial velocity is,
we know that the final relative
velocity has the same magnitude
but simply switches direction.
And that's a powerful tool in
which to analyze collisions
without doing a lot of algebra.